[Applause]
yeah i mean that's the [ __ ] world we
live in now we're comedians we got to
watch what i say
[ __ ] i went to watch an old video of
mine yesterday it had a sanction on it
by youtube
and then i scrolled and watched a
beheading video with a [ __ ] colgate
commercial in front of it that's the
[ __ ] world
this is the 10-year anniversary of
mauricio yesterday it is a 10-year
anniversary
to this day if you guys haven't seen
giannis papa's mauricio
just look it up it's to this day one of
the funniest sketches i've ever seen in
my life
but do you think i could ever i couldn't
even put that on the internet today
you know they would take it they would
do i can't even get it on the internet i
wouldn't even be able to get it
i think if you're our age or like near
that you will watch that and still think
it's funny i think if you grew up with
cancer culture
you won't understand 10 years ago things
were done right right because there's
going to be
there's going to be eventually what's
going to have to happen is you're going
to have to have
one like thing like like a netflix you
know whatever
for everybody else and disney plus and
who and all that and then one for the
for the campaign like a comedy dark web
it's going to just have to exist because
we're going to have to exist on the
comedy
we're going to have to there's because
there's no way adriana is a step in that
direction it's too popular yeah i mean
it's like
it's just too popular even i'm not going
to get political but let's just say
you look at me you look at it by the
voting the voting
70 million people voted
trump the other way yeah and i bet you a
lot of them don't mean the right way
yeah on to the right right wings that's
what i mean the right
way so it's like somebody has to say how
do you point to the right you go like
that nobody's certainly
yeah yeah that's what it is i mean
rosette when roseanne came on it was
like great
it was doing like pre
pre-table yeah pre-internet numbers
was great it wasn't very funny she's
very funny but it was serving
those people that's why i got 12 million
viewers the numbers were
bananas they were bananas like 12 15 20
million people watching it's like
pre-cable numbers so whether you like it
or not
this country money talks at some point
somebody's going to serve those people
besides andrew schultz and us
yeah that's what it is yeah yeah i mean
yeah they don't need to we're doing all
right without them getting in our market
we're cornering this pretty well
oh no dude i'm telling you i wouldn't
want to have it any other way like i
mean the success
you guys have on patreon and doing your
own thing it's like what better way to
have it where it's like
you're only known to your fans you guys
are making money hand over fish you can
say and do whatever you want i mean what
would you give that up for for a sitcom
on nbc no way
first of all and i also lose money and
it's this [ __ ] thing is like if you
have a podcast all of a sudden you're
republican or like you're [ __ ] all
right
because you make your own [ __ ] money
what is the [ __ ] republican comedian
that's why i don't vote it's like
why am i a republican comedian you know
why am i i mean when did that
when did this become like there's these
[ __ ] left i'm a left-wing comedian
then you're not a [ __ ] comedian
if you're a left-wing comedian you're
not a [ __ ] comedian put on a [ __ ]
suit hand out some pamphlets
and [ __ ] run for office you you're
always on the morally correct side
you're not a comedian you're not a
[ __ ] comedian you're an activist
what what class clown do you remember
who said the right things in class to
make you laugh
the reason we watched like in the gatsby
i'm gonna be honest the new one wasn't
bad but the old one i couldn't get
through it was just no no
i just did a corny joke i've never seen
anything enough but i would love to
watch her and she seems like a nice guy
[Laughter]
i mean we're putting that yeah kid to
work oh yeah yeah the license flickered
they've been doing that we're putting
you to work
i'm kidding around but see i should be
able to say that and not have anybody be
upset
she should be able to she i was just
kidding around i don't know the guy by
the way she
yeah by the way she looks at dress i
would think she would think that as it
was a compliment it's a [ __ ] mission
yeah thank you mission accomplished yeah
she can hit me all she wants she doesn't
care about me i'm a peon
i mean i don't know what she's going for
but it's definitely looks like she's
going for guy
whatever dude you know what i've noticed
is liberal people will love
anything offensive or like uncomfortable
if it's like they know it's scripted
like the office sure liberals love the
office it's wildly offensive
but because it's fake it's scripted
they're okay
the second it's a stand up it becomes
real to them that's why i think they
can't handle standups
right i think they're just like you know
this is this is real but for me they
can't separate themselves from comedy
right i understand but that's what i'm
saying like there's and they also are
retroactively making rules and changing
goal lines constantly so i don't like
that at all that's why i think
this space we control every aspect of it
which is the best like if you don't like
it don't listen if you don't like dude
we we talk about all the time like a
like a guy like a shane gillis
him getting canceled and getting into
his own podcast patreon space did more
for his career than snl
if he was an snl cast member you
wouldn't would have just came in yeah
i don't even know any cast members names
no i mean look i understand snl
it serves a purpose for its people i get
the people that like it like it i
totally get that but
it's just like if you want to sell
tickets and make money and be on the
internet then it's like yeah that's just
not the speed of it you know like it's
not what's gonna
you're not gonna sell tickets off that
show anymore it's just not gonna happen
you